comme j'ai dit voilà messieurs
moi j'ai rien à dire je suis scotché par
ceux de liz une écoute en boucle tout ça
génial je voulais faire profiter tous
mes amis téléspectateurs de se disent
que je leur conseille d'acheter ces
grands voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire vous n'avez rien d'autre à dire de
toute façon si juste un truc
ouais je t'écoute de femmes c'est les
angoisses et les eagles qui sont
inspirés n'ont as a way ah ouais tout le
monde croit que là on l'a sorti un peu
plus tard puisque on a essayé à vivre
bien
c
alors on va passer à l'anti portrait
chinois a organisé le voici le portrait
chinois c'est si vous étiez une fleur
lentilles portrait chine est assez si
vous étiez un [ __ ] qui seriez vous
moi dubois
ouais gomez mouais si vous étiez une
infirmité l'impuissance
pas mieux si vous étiez une drogue douce
si vous étiez un super pouvoir lire dans
les pensées pour les interrogatoires ça
peut servir
le viagra 1,6 et y ait une guerre guerre
des nerfs city une femme femme à poigne
margaret thatcher si vous étiez une
façon de mourir lapointe disons parce
qu'après ça fait six mois
si vous étiez une insulte îlotiers si
vous étiez une arme un flash ball
si vous étiez une perversion sexuelle
moi si vous étiez une opération
chirurgicale la guerre en irak
ce que vous étiez une mauvaise nouvelle
coupable si vous étiez un film raté
voilà le gendarme et les gendarmettes je
sais pas mieux si vous étiez un mauvais
rappeur
ébène way for florange si vous étiez un
très mauvais rappeur faf larage si vous
étiez à pêcher l'avarice la convoitise
et toi tu pas la gourmandise
et à tous
merci vous restez sur blanc une thèse on
va passer au blind test